voici à quoi ressemble il ya trois ans
l'ancien foyer de travailleurs migrants
au petit prêt à il encourt aujourd'hui
composé de 190 logements cette résidence
sociale accueille des travailleurs qui
connaissent des difficultés économiques
c'est adoma sociétés oeuvrant pour
l'insertion par le logement qui a dirigé
les travaux de transformation durant 24
mois
les ftm c'était des unités de vie où on
trouvait des batteries de wc des
batteries de douches et des unités de
cuisine et avec des toutes petites
chambres des chambres de 7 mètres carrés
50 aujourd'hui ses 190 logements ou le
confort de tout à chacun et se retrouve
dans ce logement et on a des ce qu'on
nomme des logements autonomes
cette résidence est ouverte à tous les
habitants ils restent généralement pour
une courte durée deux ou trois ans coût
du projet plus de 12 millions d'euros
il a été subventionné notamment par
l'état l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines ou encore la ville
d'elancourt
on doit montrer à tous les élans cortois
qu' on est toujours très à l'écouté
du social mais de le marier avec la
qualité et c'est pas facile dans un
contexte comme mondiale difficile avec
tout le problème de l'explosion
démographique que tous les pays doivent
doivent gérer ici en tout cas c'est un
modèle qualitatif dont on est fier
dans le cadre de la rénovation de ce
quartier des aménagements ont également
été réalisés aux abords de la résidence